good afternoon everybody my name is Joe
Manny
classics most of you are now familiar
friends so don't need for a long
introduction thank you for coming this
is the second lecture in the Yale Nile
initiative lecture series year or two
there'll be two more lectures in the
spring stay tuned for that these the
idea of the lecture series and the
reason why we're sitting in the
geophysics Department is that we're
trying to capture all the exciting work
that's going on in paleoclimatology
combined with history and archaeology
with the Nile River as the lens through
which we're seeing most of these these
these issues these things last week we
had a great lecture by Joe McConnell of
the DRI in ice core geochemistry and a
rather global perspective on how I
scored science ice core geochemistry
relates to paleo climate and history
today we have in a sense the opposite we
go back to kind of a very local level
and human responses at a very local
level to climactic change from the point
of view of this amazing site in the
northern sudan area at a place cut
amaura west i'm really pleased to
welcome Neil Spencer here who's come a
long way he's come from from London to
join us for about a day and a half which
is so it's a real a real effort to come
here and it's it's great to have him
Neil is the keeper the head of the
Department of Egypt and Sudanese
antiquities at the British Museum very
busy person when he's not in London he's
in the Sudan excavating he's an
archaeologist trained in Cambridge with
a BA the first part of which was in pure
and applied mathematics and then he
switched rather dramatically but it's
connected to Egyptian archaeology and
then he took a PhD at Cambridge in the
different archaeology working with the
very famous Barry Kemp today we're gonna
hear about Neil's work at Amara West by
the way this is lovely book that I got
gifted and Yale will have a copy who
doesn't already called Amara West living
in Egyptian Nubia this is really nice
summary of work published I think in
2014 it's relatively
new work neil has spent the bulk of his
career working in in the Sudan and at
this new kingdoms site in particular at
Amara West Late Bronze Age site without
further ado it's a great pleasure to
welcome Neil Spencer on the ferry onyx
Tate Nubia and the Nile and inhabitants
perspective from Amara West Thank You Jo
and it's a great pleasure to be here at
Yale it's my first time in fact and
thank you for the invitation I'll dive
straight in I'm gonna take you to Late
Bronze Age Amara West in what is now
northern Sudan before starting on our
research I just want to say that
probably like all these projects I'm
really just the interlocutor of lots of
other people's research and strands of
research that make up this very holistic
research project I want to highlight two
people in particular Saudi Abdul rubber
on the left and mohamed saad on the
right who are archaeologists from the
National Corporation of antiquities and
museums in Sudan who provide us through
the concession but also very much work
with us on the research and the
community engagement and so on and of
course there's a whole range of other
scholars who are mentioned by name as I
go through as Jo said we're gonna be
looking at these questions of
environment and how effects lived
experience from a very local perspective
in this case Amara West just to place
you chronologically and geographically
we're a downstream of the third Nile
cataract so who are the blue arrows on
the map on the left and Amara West is
founded around 1300 BC in the early
ramesside period and abandoned and I'll
come back to this towards the end of the
talk around a thousand BC and
increasingly archaeologists are
beginning to see these episodes of
Egyptian control over Nubia very much as
episodes in a much longer nubian history
so slightly reversing the perspective
through which Nubia has been looked at
over the last 200 years right to place
you in in the local environment Amara
West which is on the left there is
located just past the bend in the Nile
for the Nile is actually flowing from
the west to the east here before it
turns north again just off to
after the right of this image and as you
can see from this modeling of river flow
in particular here land below 193 metres
ASL you can see that Amara West was once
located on a very small island at the
upstream end of a very very big island
and you can see the Big Island is
defined by a northern palea channel the
thicker band of purple on this
representation here and I'm going to
come back to this landscape repeatedly
as we look at how its shaped and the
changing nature of the Nile in
particular shaped the dynamics of the
town but I'm going to start off by
looking a little bit about how the
pharaonic state intended this town to
function how that changed over time and
particularly how individual household
and local agency changed the nature of
the town over time and I'll very much
finish with the Nile and our evidence
for climate change in this in this
environment so it's an environment that
was busy with people long before the
pharaonic armies and individuals arrived
here that's nowhere eclair than on
so-called cattle rock which is about two
kilometres north of the site itself now
in the desert but once on this very big
paleo island and it's an outcrop of the
local schist rocks on which there are
bovine depictions very difficult to date
but we know they predate the ramesside
period because in one case there's an
inscription in hieroglyphs over the top
naming the describe of the temple Hattie
I so the Egyptian state in coming into
this landscape was not the first there
and there's actually evidence now
supported by c14 dates
collected by the pre historian Elena
Garcia which shows that occupation this
area goes back to 9,000 BC so we are
more interested in the the Late Bronze
Age and so as part of our project we've
been looking at the use and occupation
of the hinterland around the pharaonic
town itself in the in the in the late
second millennium BC and so the town you
can see is circled in the middle of the
map here and but between it and the
northern paleo Channel so defining this
very large island there are a whole
series of sites that were surveyed in
the 1970s by the French archaea
just andré Villa and these have been
published and we returned to some of
those sites to try and refine some of
the dating so he he map sites dating
from the neolithic period through to a
medieval christian nubian sites but we
focused on a number of sites where he
had recorded wheel turned new kingdom
pottery as he described it and what's
quite interesting here is we found a
number of what you might call ephemeral
seasonal desert encampments these were
excavated by anna stevens and some of
them were herman wire and karma classic
in date but there are a number
particularly - such as this one pictured
here - r65 that overlooks the the
ancient nile channel you can see trees
still growing in the in the paleo
channel and this dated to the early 18th
dynasty so it featured dry stone
architecture or a certain amount of mud
brick architecture and deposits and
particularly pottery that arranged in
dates from around the time of took most
us the first through until around the
time took basis the third fairly kind of
typical objects to find on a so-called
settlement site so you have jewelry
stone stone tools Flint's and so on and
also pottery very distinctive of that
era including handmade Nubian style
cooking with vessels that you can see on
the right here so these don't relate to
the occupation of Amarra West but rather
to the perhaps initial forays into the
desert exploratory forays by the
Egyptians who had already set up the
town of Sai which is located just around
the Nile Bend slightly upstream of Amara
West so here we're around 1500 to 1450
BC there's no evidence that these sites
were occupied at any time after the
reign of to it most is the third is that
because of shifting geopolitical issues
or is it more to do with the fact that
resources were exhausted or of less
interest we don't know at the moment it
will be another hundred years or so
before Amara west itself was founded so
to give you kind of the layout of the
the site itself and we're very much
approaching the site in terms of the
cemeteries are part of the town and how
they were excavated occupied and funeral
ritual took place by the inhabitants in
the town so we're lucky that our
concession includes both which is not
common in Nile Valley archeology to do
to the history of concessions but we
have the de mess
think the urban site itself in there in
the middle there the Palio channel now
dry that runs around it and then on the
desert escarpment and there are two
cemetery zones that will come on to
later so we've been excavating all three
of these areas over the last ten years
of our research project a magnetometry
survey undertaken in our first season in
2008 by colleagues from British School
in Rome showed fantastic results the
contrast between mud bricks and the
local windblown sand is very very clear
as you can see what you see here is the
wool town it's about 110 meters on a
side with in the top right corner or a
temple I'll come back to that and then a
busy array of housing or building areas
inside and also to the west to the left
of the town enclosure and you can just
see on the top the shoreline of the the
now dry river channel the nile run runs
along the bottom of this image and of
course this originally excavation in the
1930s seems to fit into a broad template
of the kind of walled enclosures the
frenetic state was building in liminal
areas but also in its colonies so you
can see for example the slightly earlier
turns of Tel Jabara and sesame and soil
on the right and then in the ramesside
period the early ramesside period places
like a moral west come through and so
it's a Moroccan and followed broadly
this template template of wall turns
with corner towers buttresses temple
within and so on evoked schematically in
in reliefs such as those from medinat
habu depicted below so as I mentioned
we're not the first to have worked
systematically at the site in the 1930s
and 1940s HW Furman led an excavation on
behalf of the Egypt exploration society
discovering a very well-preserved temple
one of the best preserved ramesside
temples are beyond the Luxor area and
standing to nearly 2.5 meters in height
and this has a fairly classic ramesside
temple layout with peristyle hypostyle
Hall and a tripartite sanctuary at the
back this was decorated in the rains of
ramesses ii and several other kings
of the of the New Kingdom right down
until Ramesses the ninth the latest
royal inscription in in Upper Nubia that
was buried the temple in the late 1940s
so is protected from the windblown sand
which fairman described as scouring the
reliefs so we haven't gone back to that
it's not been the focus of our project
but the other area that Fuhrman
excavated in the town was this large
building termed a 13.2 which was
reasonably enough identified as the
residence of the deputy of Kirsch so two
series of door jambs and door lintels
were found in some cases in situ bearing
inscriptions relating to the holders of
this title so those of you not familiar
with qur'anic Nubia there was a king son
of cush the Viceroy who oversaw Nubia on
behalf of the pharaonic state and to him
reported to individuals a deputy of cush
in control with oversight of the
northern part of lower Nubia and a
deputy of cush with oversight of the
southern part known as cush and so these
these individuals are known from other
sites in the 18th dynasty so in the two
centuries preceding Amara west and it
seems reasonable enough to posit that
Amara west is created as a new
administrative center for a seat a seat
for these deputies of cush and they're
attested in the 19th and 20th dynasty in
inscriptions from the site why they
moved to a new site is something we're
still grappling with the and I'll come
back to some of those other sites in due
course as well as the temple the other
very impressive formal monument here was
the sandstone Westgate the main entrance
into the town itself we this was
excavated by the es in the 1930s and 40s
but wery cleared it recently to
undertake a full documentation of it and
this was a space so rendered in 3d here
based on some of the color analysis we
did on the gate in 2015 this was the
most monumental expression of pharaonic
power over Nubia so one of these classic
depictions of ramesses ii going to
battle on his horse drawn chariot with a
melee of Nubian unfortunately Nubian
conquered individuals off to the right
interestingly in the temple itself
there's no depictions of Nubian battle
scenes there's actually a Near Eastern
battle scene shown in the temple so this
was the main space that that Egyptian
rhetoric or narrative was presented and
this actually presents a real battle so
one of the inscriptions here actually on
the right describes a summary of the
captives whom the powerful and strong
arm of pharaoh may be given life
prosperity and health plundered Aram one
of these Nubian toponyms being overcome
and describing 2,000 or more men 3,000
or more captives 200 or more women and
their children a total of at least seven
a half thousand individuals so it's
recording a real historical event now
other aspects of this Nubian Empire can
be a nubian colony can be explored
through the architecture partly recorded
by the AES again in the 30s and 40s so a
lot of the town is handed over or given
over towards these large storage
facilities you can see these rows of
magazines settle for corridor and the
apparatus of control is very much
evident through two other groups of
objects that survived from the town so
these are from our excavations on the
right hand side clay seal impressions
that from the reverses we can tell we're
attached to papyrus but particularly
basketry and boxes but also on the Left
we've got examples of erotic ostraca
romantic recording delivery of goods on
given days to the town I'm so suggestive
of this fair on economy of resource
extraction and presumably material being
sent sent back to to Egypt and that's
further supported by the find of a very
fine statue a block statue as you can
see on the Left found in the 1940s and
this is now in Brooklyn but it is
actually a ramesside individual who
holds the title of the scribe of
counting gold and his name was a Menem
hat and perhaps not coincidentally
fairman found buried in the corner of
one of the house houses Amara West a pot
full of gold bearing quartz that had
been hidden away by by one of the
occupants and we find in our excavations
Analia of that gold extraction so for
example example these dark stone
grinding stones with they're very
distinctive striations but also lots and
lots of quartz chippings found in the
houses so suggestive somewhat of a
cottage industry interestingly in the
micro morphology that Matt Dalton has
undertaken and I'm going to come back to
that later we encounter lots of remnants
lots of quartz grains that seem more
angular than the quartz grains we'd
expect from windblown sand or from river
works and so again perhaps reflecting
household anchored gold processing on a
small scale other kinds of activities
that we find that are perhaps associated
with this idea of a pharaonic foundation
are a some form of metallurgy workshop
the closest parallel to this in terms of
the crucibles you can see one on the
left but also we have these twe are
surviving the closest parallels very
much account here on a much larger scale
as you might expect and so scientists at
the British Museum but also Joey Owen
will have been studying this material
and what's quite nice is with the
generosity of our colleagues from n come
and Sudan we can export this material
for a whole range of scientific analysis
so we're studying both the workaday
metal objects the chisels the fish hooks
and so on but also the the flag and
learn the vitrified bricks that tell us
about this modality installation what's
interesting for me is that this is very
much confined to the very start up there
very early phases of activity in the
town and as we've indeed the evidence
for colour processing so one of my BM
colleagues cape vulture has recently
completed a study looking at evidence
for the processing of pigment and the
application of pigment so the whole Shin
apart wha a tomorrow West again availing
of the generosity of being able to take
samples out and so some of what we find
is what you might expect
so charcoal used for black red and
yellow ochre is a certain amount of
Egyptian blue perhaps imported from
Egypt itself but we also find differing
traditions so for instance the black
found in the cemetery tends to be
bitumen used as paint and for instance
in the cemetery the coffins can have
calcite used as white or as gypsum is
used in there in the town and then we
find local product
so for instance our green and blues are
not copper based but are essentially
green and blue Earth's so are these to
do with local traditions that's
something we're exploring at the moment
but so both this color evidence and the
metal evidence is very much concentrated
in the first generation or two of
occupation of the town so are we
imagining here the setting up of this
foundation the need to carve decorate
and paint the temples the deputy
residence and the West Gate and then a
fall-off in the demand for that so
that's something we're continuing to
explore so these are just some of the
examples of the palettes with all the
different ancient pigment mixes upon
them and also at that period we have
evidence of pottery production so this
is a small kiln found built onto the
natural alluvium you can almost imagine
the kind of startup operations of
building one of these towns and we also
have ostraca relating to pottery
production and delivery and these have
been studied by robbed MRA in Leiden and
the fact that Amara wes is part of a
much broader Empire is perhaps reflected
in in some of the objects we find so in
there in our very early phases we have a
cluster of these Mycenaean stirrup jars
and what's quite interesting here is
that we have with hans mommsen and BOM
in Bonn University I should say done a
neutron activation analysis on these and
they seem to come from production places
in Cyprus and the Peloponnese so we're
very much part a tomorrow west of a
broad network throughout the the early
ramesside empire and finally just
looking at this from the kind of
pharaonic state's perspective we can go
up to the cemetery and so in our high
cemetery which is where the elite were
buried we have these pyramid chapels so
they're modest in size but quite big as
as private pyramids go so this one is 11
meters square with a small chapel in
front that had a shaft in the middle of
it leading to rock-cut burial chambers
cut into the bedrock that is across the
whole local area so our cemetery
excavations and the bio archeology
itself have been led by mikela bender
from the Austrian archaeological
Institute and we have a range of
cemetery
types of grave types in the in the two
cemeteries as I'll show you but what
became clear with our excavations in
these pyramids is that we have the first
evidence that the deputies of cush were
actually buried in in Amara West so here
four sub T's of the deputy of cush
pastor who's the guy we saw on one of
the earlier inscriptions from the
residential building in the town
previous scholars before our project had
started had posited that the Egyptians
had all left Damara west following the
collapse of the the New Kingdom Empire
in Nubia and had buried their dead at
home and which isn't really consistent
with what you find elsewhere so this
kind of up ends that that idea and I'm
going to come back to abandonment in the
end of the settlement later in the talk
one of the really exciting things in the
in the cemetery is we've been
undertaking strontium isotope analysis
on the dental enamel principally to look
at aspects or information evidence that
might shed light on migration and the
region of origin of individuals so as
I'm sure many of you are aware the
strontium isotope ratio that you can
recover from teeth is essentially
reflecting your intake particularly of
water but also things that rely on water
so plants animals fish and so on so
there tends to be a local local
signature although work recently has
shown that that signature can very much
vary depending on the period you're
looking at so you need local and
contemporary control points but what's
interesting in our cemetery is you have
a lot of a cluster of samples down down
the book down below which very much
seemed to fit with the local signature
for this time on the basis of silt
deposits but also rodent remains other
animal remains and so on but we have
several outliers the LR on top which is
a very high value is actually a pre
karma tomb that sits oddly enough within
our cemetery so that's perhaps explains
that it's chronological difference but
this is much more interesting these
seven individuals here come from two of
two tombs a tomorrow s and there are two
of those elite Parrott the pyramid tombs
one perhaps associated with this
individual call ebuy with a very fine
mirror buried with him so it just leaves
the question as to whether at some
periods the elite were from some
else where that might be whether
somewhere else in Nubia or somewhere
else in Egypt is still open to
discussion and we may never never know
but it's interesting as we think a lot
about Egyptian and Nubia you've been
cultural entanglement we have to
remember that when this town was founded
in 1300 BC there have been so-called
pharaonic towns in Nubia in this region
like Sai for 200 years already
so what did it mean to be Egyptian or
Nubian and we rather like to think about
a shifting range of identities that
people associated with them depending on
circumstance and I'll come back to that
a little bit later so that kind of gives
you a perspective in terms of the
pharaonic state I want to say a little
bit now about things from a local
perspective before I come on to how the
Nile shaped all of this
so as Egyptologist we often look at
these plans of buildings and use terms
such as temple town which i think is
actually deeply problematic when we
start looking at the distinctive nature
of all of these settlements in Nubia so
the talk of the term temple town was
coined in the in the early 1970s to
refer to these new kingdom towns with
their walled enclosures their fortified
appearance and the fact was a temple
usually at the center of them they often
vary quite considerably in size and I'd
also like to just quickly give you a
flavor of how much they vary in in in
purpose and particularly their dynamic
histories before returning to Amara west
so this gives you an idea of some of the
size variation from the massive
enclosures that Sesa be and so those are
made in late 18th dynasty to the much
smaller towns of the ramesside period
such as mr West at Sai you're on the
edge of a very big island you have an
occupation spanning from the reign of
mozi on words right through the two
moseyed period and into at least the
early ramesside period so you knew but
because recent work has shown that
there's a burial of a deputy of cush of
the early ramesside period called hornet
there so there's a big question about
the relationship between the two towns
but there seems to be very little
ramesside activity after this if we go
somewhere like sesame there's a similar
picture with a foundation in the early
18th dynasty but then a massive
enclosure and temple complex built in
the late 18th dynasty and again this
this is a
on a very different setting so it's on a
big alluvial bank along the side of the
Nile in a fertile agricultural reach and
again very little evidence after the
reign of SETI the first when you go
somewhere like Tom bus there's a much
more continuous story that can be told
and so building on the work of Stewart
Tyson Smith over the last 15 years or so
relying on the cemetery although parts
of the the town and the fortified
enclosure have now been found
you have both pyramid tombs of say the
early mid 18th dynasty but you also have
these two Mueller's burials a very
Nubian form of a funerary marker and
some of them have been carbon-dated the
remains within them right back to the
ramesside period so you've got a
continuity of tradition here and a
continuity of occupation right down into
what Egyptologists call the 25th dynasty
so 8th 7th century BC so very different
histories to these places when we go a
bit further south into the the heart of
the dambulla reached the kind of
agricultural heartland of Nubia across
most of its history at the sight of Cour
which was excavated by the Sudan
archaeological research Society and
Derek Wells be over the last 30 or so
years there you have very little
knowledge about the New Kingdom town
there's a temple of Tutankhamun there
but this is a site that flourished right
into the Merritt ik period so over over
thirteen fourteen centuries and then
when we go into the the hinterland of
Cour so it's 25 down to the right again
has been excavated by the Sudan
archaeological Research Society
this is one of those rare examples of a
rural site that's been excavated in this
region the Nile Valley so much of what
we know depends on these big urban
centers founded by the pharaonic state
and so this is a site that spans
chronologically the Kurama classic
period so before the egyptian invasion
and right through until the Knapton
periods are long after the egyptian
occupation of this region this is not a
walled town they're storage facilities
here there's housing areas and I think a
to better understand this
this ancient colony is it where we're
going to need to excavate more of these
sites or different kind of living
environments in the coming years so I
hope that gives you a flavor of how all
these places are very different and I
haven't talked about well that slide of
Kara Madoka Gayle this has obviously be
center of the the kurma state before
the arrival of the Egyptian Egyptian
armies in the 15th century BC a
sprawling metropolis when the great
urban centers in in ancient Africa again
a very different history with with New
Kingdom temples built to the north of it
and then I haven't even talked about
places we know so little about so
there's Egyptian temples that Solar burn
at jebel barkal where we know almost
nothing about the ancient towns so all
of that to say that we need to look at
the very individualized histories of
these sites and I would say start to
look a little bit more about how the
individuals the households and the
communities that lived there start to
shape the trajectories of these sites
and ultimately the trajectories of
Empire if you will and the end of empire
so a couple of examples that are
tomorrow West is I set out earlier the
the wall town and how within it there
was areas for storage there was a temple
there's the deputies of residence that
all sounds quite official and
appropriately pharaonic but actually at
no point do they seem to have laid out
houses in an orderly fashion so we don't
find the barracks or the terrace like
rows of houses that you find say in a
workman's village at Amarna but also say
at places like sesame which are late
18th dynasty I'm just just upstream of
here rather this rather what they've
done is leave space for communities to
self organize and so this is a series of
three small houses with their central
rooms tucked away into the southwestern
corner of the town and built on the
natural alluvial surfaces this is one of
the first things built on this site so
they're not controlling how people are
living obviously the houses of certain
similarities with all people need in
their dwelling spaces but there's
already a sense of community agency
emerging here so that just gives you an
example of one of those houses and you
get hearts and grinding emplacements all
the typical things you might imagine
tucked into the corner inside corner of
the town wall and this really starts a
story of how the town changes and we
have focused on this area in the
northwestern corner of the town and this
is one of these storage facilities here
and in gray with his three long
corridors maricon magazines and it's
probably bit difficult to see but on the
bottom-left within a generation or two
all of those buildings were raised so
that to the ground leaving them only
maybe one or two brick courses height
and over the top were built a
of houses and so what I'm showing you
here is on the right where the sandbags
heart are this is the north wall the
outside wall the deputies residence and
at some point people are building into
this alleyway between it and the house
that house to the left so there's this
process of a colonizing colonization of
space and it ends up with areas that
once had a series of very organized
appearing storage magazines turning into
dense clusters of dwellings so here you
can see nine houses shaded in red so a
real neighborhood developing around a
series of alleyways and in white in the
middle is one of the old storage
magazines that effectively becomes the
local rubbish dump it's never built in
again and this is just to the north of
the deputy's residence so the most kind
of official or formal place within the
town and this is happening within a
generation or two of Amarra West being
founded so the the vision of the
pharaonic state is being changed rather
radically by inhabitants and as you can
see the houses are not laid out as a
group they're individually shaped built
into over and onto the remains and the
partly demolished remains of the earlier
storage facilities and this just gives
you an example of one of the houses and
Amarra West is turning out to be one of
those places that reminding us that
house topologies are are very very
suspect things in many ways they tend to
reduce things to a rather orderly state
that we don't see reflected on the
ground so every house is different
there's certain things that reappear
staircases back rooms without formal
floors a formal space in the middle as
you can see here with a master Burr and
often separate Suites of rooms for ovens
and and grinding emplacements but every
single house is different in its layout
and then they I suppose about a hundred
years into the occupation of the town
and things there's another big shift and
so this this topographic map shows you
the kind of the the smallest extent of
the island MROs in terms of when the
Nile flood was very very high and what
you can see is it actually creates a
Garden Island as we call it which was
separated from the main town by probably
a perennial II inundated channel perhaps
only during the time of the flood we
call this a Garden Island as we found a
whole series of gridded garden plots
on it and so this the areas outside the
town seemed to have been a combination
of rubbish dumping ground and places for
small garden plots in the early history
of the town so some of those garden
plots shown here as you can see and
these are well known from other sites
and even tomb paintings but soon enough
things became rather crowded inside the
town walls and you've got this sprawl
develops this suburb as we call it to
the west of the West Gate that's in the
middle of the shot there and so
initially these are very big houses that
are laid out I'm so villas if you will
some of them are four hundred square
meters an area so four or five six times
bigger than those inside the town walls
but then soon enough there's a colonizer
the colonization of space between them
and it becomes another very cluttered
neighborhood so this gives you an idea
here on the right one of these very big
villas we unlike Amarna we don't have
any names of the individuals who lived
in each in each house there are
sometimes inscribed doorways but none of
them bear the names of individuals and
you can see here in its latest phase
they're kind of higgledy-piggledy spread
of buildings with small alleyways in
between so again you're not saying a
planned state-driven array of housing
areas as you might have seen so for
instance within the wool town accessibly
and this change is very much the
appearance and the relationship to those
very formal monuments of the pharaonic
state so the this is the entrance to the
the town wall rendered in 3d by dave
fletcher and you can see the the stone
gateway with its two titular ease of
ramesses ii carved on it with the
development to the western suburb it
ends up being in a pit that they
maintained and so you had to step down
into the town and so it's interesting to
think about you know the pharaonic state
placing such a piece of rhetoric and
narrative on the outside walls of the
town but then that becoming part of the
town and kind of swallowed up by ER as
it were as that as the town grew over
time now what we can also do in the
houses of course is look at variants in
approaches to everything from food ways
to ritual to the use of space and again
picking up on the architecture which is
very macro and getting down to a micro
level through
what you might expect botanical and
fallen analysis but also using
geochemistry and micro morphology we can
start to pick out nuances between the
houses and the different lived
experience within those spaces so just
to provide you two examples of that are
our formal remains show very different
processing of animal parts from some of
the small houses to some of the big
villas particularly in relation to the
hind hind cuts of cattle and I can say
here that the the former remains here
very much what you'd expect to find in
New Kingdom Egypt at this period so a
lot of cattle pig but also AM sheep and
goat and a certain amount of wild animal
they're not much and then the the
botanical analysis which comprised both
macro botanics so that's desiccated and
burnt seeds but also phytoliths study
which allows us to look at things like
Leafs and so on otherwise survive in the
archaeological record or can't be traced
so this is work done by Philippa Ryan
and again you have this very clear
division much more reliance on on Emmer
in the Emmer wheat in the large houses
compared to the use of barley and some
of the other spaces and so that opens up
all sorts of questions in terms of
redistribution in terms of storage and
also the question of supply where this
agriculture was taking place and I'll
come back to that later another area
that has been very interesting in terms
of the micro morphological research
undertaken by Matt Dalton at University
of Cambridge so this is mounting small
columns of sedimentary deposits on
slides curing them
sorry curing them mounting them on
slides and then looking at them under
high magnification and so this is just
one example of that research which is
picking up areas of low medium and high
intensity animal presence within housing
areas so some of it's perhaps not
surprising and some of the kind of
lean-to parts of buildings the outer
parts buildings were picking up aspects
of both pig but also sheep and goat
coprolites
and sometimes they're very heavily
trampled suggesting of long-term panning
of animals in those spaces but we're
also finding for instance pigs being
kept in some spaces particularly around
the bottom of staircases in houses where
as we
fine cattle survey being passed at
somewhere else on the site or are they
being delivered from somewhere else and
these are all questions that were only
embarking on at the at the moment and as
I said the the phytoliths study so these
are the silica caste left behind from
plants is telling us about a lot of the
types of plants that we don't pick up in
the more macro record and so for
instance Philippa Ryan and Matt Dalton
have recently been looking at the
evidence for done and picking up lots of
evidence for instance of cereal
processing waste but also dicot leaves
so perhaps from sycamore fig and so on
being part of the diet being fed to
these animals so this is all information
that you don't get from the macro
remains and I think one of the
challenges facing us in the future those
of us working in the nile valley is how
to align this with the data from egypt
itself where you can't get this
resolution because of the difficulties
of scientific archaeology moving back to
the macro level we find distinctions
between the houses so for instance here
two houses set on either side of an
alleyway one has a massive cluster of
pallets so shards broken broken pottery
shards being used to mix paint on the
other side of the alley there seems to
be a real focus on Flint working both
using local and imported Flintstone so
this is something we're working through
but always with this angle of looking at
it from the perspective of the
individuals and the different activities
going on the different feel and ambiance
to the different spaces within the town
and cult is another thing we can look at
so I'm not talking about the temple but
again very much the experience of those
in the houses we do find on awestruck
earth depictions of things that you
might find familiar from Egypt so here
two arms offering a small image of the
god Amun rather as a ram head and we
actually have that in stone dedicated by
an official who's shown on the bottom
right that was found in the temple in
the 1930s and is now in the museum in
Khartoum we also in one of our houses
found an anthropoid busts in situ these
are often called ancestor busts so this
was placed on a pedestal in the in the
back room of a house so there's a
consistency with with practice that you
might find in contemporary ramesside
Egypt we also find evidence so this is
reconstructed from lots of small
fragments evidence of painted shrines
with architectural
motifs redolent of temple architecture
so it could better cornice and then of
the tourist molding and so on as three
of these known from houses within the
town Adam at Amara West but going back
to the micro level again we're picking
up evidence for other activity that may
be ritual in in purpose and form so
going back to the micro morphology here
what we what matt has noticed as a
series of red splashes concentrated
around doorways and stairwells in the
houses and on first appearance these
were described by myself and other
excavators as red ochre you know
splashes careless splashes of paint as
something was happening in these houses
but Matt's mapping of these has shown
there's actually a consistent appearance
of where they are but also that they're
not made of ochre so FTIR analysis has
shown these are actually made from
crushed up sedimentary rocks there's a
high kalyan component to them and
they're clustering around doorways but
also around pot stand emplacements and
particularly in the rooms with the
master burrs suggest there may be some
ritual function to these they don't seem
accidental and there's a lot of
different rocks being used in the
crushing to crush and create this
pigment what seems to be important is
the red having this red and door being
out on certain places within the houses
and this is another area where you get
these red deposits so this is in one of
the mastaba rooms in our houses you
could have one of these low benches on
the right and you can see the deposit up
there of red associated with some sort
of drainage basin perhaps also with a
basketry or a ceramic pot stand and so
one of the ideas that we've been playing
with is are these associated with ritual
activity and there are parallels at
places like like a skirt but as I said
none of this would have been picked up
with macro archeology other aspects of
ritual we find in the houses of these
clay figurines so these have been
studied by Anna Stevens and what's
interesting here and this is where I'm
coming on to the the kind of nubian
influence in terms of material culture
is we have two very different traditions
so on the left you have these plaque
like figures rectangular and section
orphan with little decorative details of
say the pubic area or perhaps the fringe
of a dress on the top
or the hem of a dress on the right you
have this very different tradition
creating two rolls of clay and putting
them together to create a much more
anthropomorphic representation of a
woman and it was quite interesting here
is the ones on the right cluster and the
later occupation phases of the town so
are we looking at here of a development
of a more local tradition and another
aspect of that is a kind of curation of
older objects so here in one of these
small trapezoid shaped houses tucked
inside the town wall so we're here in
the early twentieth dynasty probably we
find these three Karma style axe heads
perhaps collected from one of these
sites in the desert curated if you will
brought together and buried together in
this house presumably with the knowledge
of them being very old things so one of
the things we've got to think about with
these the people living in this space
yes they're defined by the pharaonic
architecture around them but they're
also interacting with the desert and a
very long history of occupation with a
very different iconography and a
material culture and that is nowhere
clearer than this building which remains
a unique er MROs there may be some more
of them this is a building a 12-11 that
falls into our falls outside the
egyptian architectural tradition it has
much more in common with the type of
round and oval houses and other
buildings you find at karma on a much
larger scale but there's also buildings
of this type perhaps at Cour in the
early first millennium BC so what you
have is a two roomed oval structure
sitting right next to the building on
the bottom is that the large villa I
showed you earlier so this is late 19th
early 20th to see and date the pottery
is not distinct from any of the pottery
and the other houses around it but it's
a very obviously different architectural
tradition and so the ability of that
material expression of adherence to a
different identity right within the
heart of the pharaonic town is very
interesting and there are other aspects
that we think are inconsistent with
Egyptian material culture so we have a
lot of these storage jars some of them
imported from outside Egypt some of them
are ASIS where where we've got these
wild animals carved into them so is that
another local tradition these are post
farrowing carvings but nowhere we do we
see this entanglement better and this
adherence to different identities than
in our summit
so I showed you some of the pyramid
Tunes that seem to fit with ramesside
cemeteries throughout the Nile Valley
but also we've got this tomb so this is
grave 2 4 4 it was excavated in 2014 and
15
bye-bye Michaela bender bender and her
team on the surface you've got a low
tumorous formed of a mound of Earth
capped with local black shift stones
this is a very very nubian and age-old
Nubian form of funerary marker but
what's interesting is it doesn't have an
offset niche single barrier when insider
as you might expect rather as you can
see in section above it has three burial
chambers and those burial chambers are
much more consistent with what we find
in the Egyptian style pyramid tombs so
what's interesting here is that this
individual or this actually this family
group have created a monument that is
identifying with Nubian culture on the
surface but inside they want all the EAM
all the accoutrements of a of an
Egyptian burial so you have a file Silla
You've Egyptian star pottery there's no
Nubian star pottery in this barrier you
have scarabs but you also have decorated
anthropoid coffins in very bad condition
but we pick up small fragments of them
so and this is this is during the period
when the pharaonic empire is controlling
this area as far as we know so there was
obviously the ability of people to
identify with these different cultural
traditions however throughout this
period and this becomes very marked when
we leave the era of Egyptian control the
the tumulus as a burial and these single
niche burials never go away and once we
get past that the New Kingdom occupation
of Nubia you see a flourishing or an
increase in the number of these graves
that are marked by to me like they have
objects that you know I mean this is a
beautiful image of best carved in ivory
but in a tradition that's slightly
different from what we see in Egypt at
that period and they are buried still in
painted coffins but often on funerary
beds which again are a tradition that
goes back to the karma period in in
Nubia so this is just an example of some
of those funerary beds that Manuela
lemon has been studying and
interestingly here they don't the bed
legs don't fit with the tradition of
karma nor do they fit with the tradition
contemporary New Kingdom Egypt as
evidenced in both royal tombs but also
places like Daryl Medina and so on so
again there's this idea of local hybrid
traditions being created on site
unsurprisingly pottery tells us a lot
about this so several of our ceramicists
and particularly mikelis Pateros the
scientists at the british museum have
been working on the the fabrics of our
pottery and what's interesting here is
the very distinctive Egyptian style
wheel throw and pottery distinctively
fitting with the styles of the period
back in Egypt itself such as this red
rim Bowl on the top right and the the
cooking ware so there's these Nubian
hand-formed orphan basket and pressed
vessels they're often made of the same
clay which we cannot identify
microscopically but rather through
petrographic analysis back in the lab
and we have crossover examples we have
examples of Egyptian style pottery made
by hand so not on a wheel so this is now
of course pots are not people or don't
equate to people but it's interesting
that you have both these traditions and
crossover traditions taking place within
the town so that gives you a kind of
perspective firstly from the pharaonic
state than the individual agency
community agency and particularly the
visibility of nubian cultural traditions
within the town and so i'd like to
finish up by talking about the role of
climate and i suppose this is where it
fits with with with jose nile initiative
series most closely and i'm going to
prevent to present very briefly the
evidence we have for the the change in
climate and the changing nile regime but
then i really want to focus on how that
affected life in the town and how we can
track both from the by archaeological
evidence but also architectural evidence
how people responded to that and
eventually left this area so Amara West
today looks like this so I'm looking
here from the desert escarpment the the
pyramid cemeteries behind me across the
narrow dry Channel the town mound is
just under the under the label there and
then the tamarisk in acacia trees that
line the Nile today and looking across
to djebel bura the mountain on the other
side of the Nile which overlooks
overlooks I so that's what it looks like
today but we actually think Amara West
in ancient times probably looked a
more like this so this kite photo at the
top actually looks upstream from Amara
West to the island of our Netta that is
actually where our dig house is located
and I have to say that living in the mud
houses there and experiencing the
environment has has been incredible in
terms of informing how we interpret the
ancient site in a materiality
perspective so what you can see there is
Renetta Island is hugging the west bank
of the Nile it's got a smaller channel
to the north side that smaller channel
often becomes almost dry during the
winter and then of course Rises with the
na flood each year although that's
changing with the damerov dams that have
been built and what you can see I mean
it's really stark in that image above
you can see sand on the right I should
stress that if you leave Amara West and
head north you walk through the desert
until you hit the Mediterranean its
Sahara the whole way and the winds are
northerly so windblown sand was a
problem for us as excavators and as
we'll see was a problem in ancient times
so the sand on the on the on the West
Bank then you have the series of what
I've been told are termed Fighter
genetics and dunes
so these develop around the trees some
of them are 15 meters in height and so
the trees the sand dunes and the water
body of course provide a barrier and you
can see there's no yellow sand on Amara
on Araneta Island the island and the top
image and of course the main channel
provides a barrier to sand getting
across to the east bank of the known
I'll come back to that bank later you'll
see there the small island on the left
on the far left of the image has this
gray reworked River sound very different
from the yellow sound we can see that's
coming in windblown from that from the
Sahara so from the 1930s HW Fuhrman had
already posited Amara West was on an
island but we wanted to get independent
dating evidence for that
and so this River work has been led by
Jamie Woodward and Mark Macklin who I
know can speak here last year and it's
their work that has really informed this
new reading of the chronology of Amara
West but also potentially the reason for
its abandonment so I just wanted you to
bear these two images in mind as we as
we go back to what is now a very arid
Amara West this just gives you an idea
from the from the river this is very
close to Mr
West how you look up at these sand dunes
some of them 15 meters high with these
acacia and tamarisk trees so visibility
of the ancient town would have been very
restricted from the Nile in ancient
times and of course we've been
undertaking work on charcoal which does
suggest that tamarisk
sycamore fig a case were very common in
ancient times at the site most of the
charcoal we have is of those species so
we think the environment was quite
similar in that sense and here you can
see a modeling by one of Jamie and
Mark's colleagues Andrew hard hardy
showing a simulation of flood water
depth on the basis of the highest known
Nile discharge in more recent times and
so you can see here again a similar
pattern the big palea channel to the
north creating this massive Island with
MROs being a very small island off it
and I think we've got to think of this
as a shifting dynamic landscape so
through the 200-250 years of occupation
Amara West might partly being joined to
the larger island may have become
disjoined from it and you delivered a
series of braided braided channels
throughout this area this map actually
shows you where the Nile turns back to
the to the north just on the top top
right there
so in terms of trying to understand this
landscape in a bit more detail we
undertook ground-penetrating radar
survey so this was done by colleagues
from the Russian School in Rome again
and you might just be able to see on the
radar plot the the curve so if you
ignore the main noise the main kind of
banding just at the top you'll see
you're looking at essentially a virtual
section and you can see the shape of the
of the Nile Channel and so the the Nile
channel ranged from thirty-five to six
meet 60 metres in width on the basis of
this and we were what we were able to do
was sink a series of slot trenches and
sawn Dodgers not through the archaeology
but through to the edge of the town
through this channel and the reason we
want to do that was to get deposits out
that we could date particularly through
optically stimulated luminescence dating
and what we found there was quite a
surprise so what you can see on the Left
are a series of banking now filter
posits so these are
either individual flood layers or more
probably an accumulation of different
flood layers very dark dark brown Nile
silts interleaved with windblown sand
deposits some of the metres in depth and
so what we're looking at here is a
series of flood events and in between
them periods when there's no water and
the windblown sand is blowing in from
the north and accumulating and so the
optically stimulated luminescence dating
is done on sand particles that provides
if you will a kind of chronological
framework for dating the North filt
deposits in between and we were also
able to do carbon-14 dating on charcoal
found within some of the deposits tumble
from the town that's not as reliable
because of course it could be older
charcoal but it provides actually
support for the for the dating
conclusions from the OSL dates and what
we found in this trench to the left is
that it was only at the very very base
that we found the perennial river
deposits so when the water was flowing
on a regular basis and that seems to be
banded by a date you can see down here
so the earliest flood the earliest
perennial Nile filt deposits when the
river is flowing seemed to date before
12:00 70 BC now there's an error to
either side of 100 years we don't think
it's earlier because that would be
before the founding of the town and the
town is actually orientated towards the
Nile so the temple faces that small Nile
channel the temple gateway faces that
way the two historical Steeler place
there and so on but what Mark and Jamie
think is that essentially very soon
after the town was founded perhaps
within a generation or so that Nile
channel stopped flowing regularly and
then what we have in this schematic
sequence is you can see six more flood
events that happen between the late
second millennium BC and down to about
200 BC and there hasn't been water in
this channel ever since and we don't
think that's a process of erosion that
has removed layers further above we
think this is actually an accurate
record of when when Nile silts have been
deposited in this space so this gives
you an idea in in section so it's a
small channel to the north on the right
of the the section above and you can see
it's these grain Isles silts at the
bottom here which is when the channel
was flowing
and then would have been reactivated
when there was higher Nile floods and so
what's interesting here is that it
suggests for a large period of the
town's history the Nile wasn't flowing
per annually in this space and may not
even have come down here on an annual
basis and so this has a big effect in
terms of how we understand the the
ancient climate and think back to those
images I showed you of Araneta Island if
we imagine a starting point of that
we're essentially moving towards an
increasingly arid environment more
windblown sand and there may have been
parries for agriculture was possible
fees in that agriculture was possible in
these dried up channels you still find
that in Nubia today but ultimately you
would have had an increasing ingress of
windblown sand less protection from it
because of course you'd also have the
erosion of the dunes and the the failure
of the of the treeline on the opposite
bank and we start to see that in various
ways we see it very much today when we
excavate so probably two or three days a
year we have to stop excavation because
we can't see anything so the wind is
really strong quite dispiriting if
you've excavated a room and it fills up
again overnight but we're very much
aware of how horrific it is to work in
these circumstances let alone to try and
practice agriculture and so we approach
this through three other angles so how
do people respond to this very evident
climatic change so one is we wanted to
get a sense of whether it was very
evident within the town so we went back
to Matt and his micro morphology so we
went into one of the alleyways that I
showed you a picture of her earlier
between the deputy's residence and a
housing block and we took a series these
black rectangles are a series of micro
morphology columns that as you can see
they're being coated in plaster of Paris
to be removed and shipped back to
Cambridge and what Matt was able to do
here through laser particle size
analysis was look at the proportions of
sand in these deposits and what's really
interesting is you go from the early
deposits so we're early in the
nineteenth dynasty around 1300 BC
through about a hundred years where your
son layers are about 32 sorry about 25
to 35 percent and then they jump up into
the 50s and 60s when we get into the
latest phases of occupation and I
I should stress this is not just when
the town's been abandoned there is
answer per genic activity going on we've
got flora surface we've got deposits mud
floor surfaces kind of de facto flora
surfaces in the in the alleyway so there
seems to be a real increase in the
amount of sand that's windblown so this
very distinctive yellow sound compared
to the the silt that's probably just
eroding away from the mud brick
buildings and it's interesting going
back to our nest Island where we live
you don't see yellow sand lying around
the desert it's not very far away but
it's on the other side of the Nile the
other side of that barrier of sand dunes
and and trees you find a lot of it's
very very dusty place to live but it's
it's it's gray it's grey reworked river
silt and also now silt presumably eroded
out of the mud brick houses so there's a
big change here and Matt did a similar
study in the western suburb where it was
even more marked so that presumably even
more exposed to the to the wind given
it's not within the wall town had even
higher levels are over Olli and sand now
how did the inhabitants deal with this
well on a kind of city level if not a
state level we perhaps have the building
of this stone wall outside the town wall
this is best seen in the archive images
from the 1930s as you can see here so
this is a sizable structure still today
and it only defines the northwestern
corner or sorry surrounds the
northwestern corner and north wall so
facing the wind and the early and sand
and so I wonder if this is actually
being built to protect the the foot of
the enclosure wall so what we see with
buildings as they erode in this area
today is it's the bottom of the
buildings that are undermined first and
then you have the collapse of the wall
so is that to protect against that we
don't know of course but it's it's a
plausible interpretation but then we can
see on a household level how people are
dealing with this and so deposits are
building up outside their houses outside
the front door of their houses and
sometimes that's rubbish so kind of I
suppose with classical case of antiquity
just throw your rubbish outside the
front door and gradually the rubbish
accumulates outside and you need a
staircase down into your house that's
the case in most of our houses but
because of the micro morphology we know
the later levels are much more to do
with windblown sand than any other
deposits and so people start
building these sand traps so they reuse
architecture so bits of lintels
doorjambs grinding stones also a little
bit of mud brick wall and just packed
mud to create these little entrance ways
so you can stop the sand coming into
your house and you can step and step
down into the house and what we see in
the western suburbs so I've marked in in
white here some of the doorways there's
only one house in the western suburb
that was stupid enough to have a doorway
facing north everyone else had been
facing south away from the away from the
prevailing wind and in fact that house
which had the northern facing door I'm
sorry this is another house just to show
you this sequence of you have a front
door and even extension in another front
door and they're putting these blockings
in front of both of them as they try and
dealing with this increasing sound but
this is the house which had the front
door facing north that's in the front of
your and of the image here and you can
see they've they've put a blocking in
front of it they've added another door
to the bottom left that needed a
blocking and eventually they turn the
front door of the house back over to the
to the west so away from the prevailing
wind so we can see on a kind of macro
architectural level how people are
coping with these issues and then
because it's a project where we've got
both the cemetery evidence and the
so-called town side is our bio
archaeological analysis of the skeletons
can tell us a lot about what's happening
and what we find we have a dataset of
180 skeletons so statistically
significant although we have less of the
New Kingdom than we would like quite a
number of them are post New Kingdom in
date but what we find is the post New
Kingdom ones you're seeing increased
evidence of stress on the body so some
of those things might be to do with a
general deterioration and living
conditions so increase for instance
caries dental abscesses but what's
really interesting is we have a notable
increase in respiratory diseases and so
this is shown through new bone formation
on the sinuses but also on the inside of
the ribs suggesting a series of diseases
that are affecting the soft tissue and
thus affecting the bone so it's
suggestive of a place where people are
finding it harder to live their body is
recording more stress and perhaps we
have to think about a gradual
abandonment
where agriculture was becoming more and
more difficult and that process of
abandonment and we might be able to see
in the archeology and I think what we're
trying to do is make it a little bit
more nuanced than maybe a major logical
literature where there's this idea
almost of the ramesside state loses
control of Nubia and all these towns
they kind of turn off the lights close
the doors and bring everything home to
Egypt and I think that's I'm simplifying
a little bit but I think that's very
problematic because do these people
think of Egypt as home many of them may
have had nubian cultural affiliations
but also may have been parts of families
who'd lived in this region for
generations and generations and been
buried in this region most importantly
but we do find examples of houses
perhaps being prepared for abandonment
so in our big Villa someone has
dismantled a doorway and very carefully
collect collected the lintel four parts
of the door jamb and the door threshold
all in the same place as if they're
about to take it somewhere and in such
an environment I think the two most
valuable commodities in in these
abandoned houses are the the roofing
beams Wood is scarce here and the
prepared stone stone is also good
quality stone is very very scarce in
this in this region and so what we're
probably finding happening and looking
at the evidence from the of roofing that
may abandon Bush has studied we don't
have any of the organics remaining I
presume a lot of the beams were taken
away but a lot of the matting and
grasses probably just rotted away or
been eaten by termites but the
impressions left on the mud as you can
see on this modern Nubian house tell us
a lot about the roofing but that would
have probably been the first thing thing
to go and then again living in these
villages has told us a lot about how
houses fall apart and I know some work
was done a by Barry Kemp on this but
what's interesting I think in these
villages is you don't have fully
abandoned villages on the whole often
you have houses that are abandoned
temporarily so they're bricked up
doorways are bricked up the door is
locked
and they're left someone's gone to
Khartoum or to Saudi Arabia or sometimes
built a house on the other side of the
Nile because the agriculture is better
but they're often kept and used on a
seasonal basis during festivities like
the eid and so on but then eventually
you do have abandonment and you see
examples here on the right of a house
where the roof beam
which would have been a metal or of palm
trunks have been taken away because
they're valuable the house-door also
have wood has been taken away and then
eventually you have the archaeological
process happens that leads to something
on the bottom left so we're probably
dealing with quite a drawn-out process
of abandonment and then the question is
where do these people go
and so I'm positing here very much that
the abandonment is due to climate change
not due to the the power vacuum left by
the Egyptian state we know retreating we
know for instance in the second
Intermediate Period that places that
were Egyptian foundations continue to be
occupied with people pledging allegiance
to Nubian Kings
I think of places like Bhutan and so
there's no reason to think people would
have left this area if it was still a
viable place to live in and I think this
this Google Earth image shows very
starkly how the yellow sand doesn't get
across the river nor does it get to the
islands and pretty much from the early
first millennium BC right until today
settlement is focused on the east bank
of the Nile is the South Bank here so
that's where you find the big medieval
Christian cemeteries that's where you
find the meriting center of our East
it's where you find the modern town of
ivory and it's also where you find one
of the largest cemeteries excavated in
Nubia of Miss Amenia this was excavated
in the 1970s by andré villa has napat
inand miss him in Serena Burton and Mara
Witek tombs but some of the Knapton
tombs might be very much post New
Kingdom so early first millennium BC and
the settlement associated with these
haven't been found but it's very
tempting to think this as the place
where many of the inhabitants of MROs
moved to perhaps over quite a long
period of time but it wasn't the end of
a moral West sorry wasn't the end of
Amara West the cemetery continued to be
used for two or three centuries after we
have no evidence of settlement now we're
very much affected by sand erosion and
crunk ation of the architecture and MROs
we do have some pottery that goes down
to the 7th 8th and 7th century BC but no
architecture associated with it it's
possible all the architecture has been
eroded away although I find that a
little bit surprising
but the model were working on at the
moment is actually that the town may
have largely been abandoned but the
cemetery continued to be used as a
ancestral burial place so people going
back to bury their dead perhaps in
in in places where their family had been
buried and what we're finding is new
tombs built in the ninth eighth and
seventh century BC these are nearly all
tumor lie so more of a kind of nubian
visual identity to them but we're also
finding the old tombs are the subject of
what we term ancestor cult so in tombs
that were occupied in the ramesside
period had a number of burials we find a
kind of restarting of cults at those
tombs with evidence of eighth and
seventh century but offering pottery
left on the exterior and in the shaft of
the tombs are not associated with
burials so I think we need to think of
this a process of abandonment we need to
move away from ideas about the Egyptian
state but we also need to move away from
ideas about happening very quickly it
probably happened over quite a long a
long period of time this is an example
of one of those pyramid tombs from the
nineteenth dynasty with a much later
vessel found in the in the offering
court outside so I just want to sum up
by saying where we've been doing this
for 10 years there's a lot more analysis
to do we've stopped excavating we're at
the stage of study seasons at the moment
going back in January and February but
we're really only beginning to unpick
kind of threads of evidence that cut
across all these analytical streams of
research we've been doing and I think
our focus in the coming years is really
going to be to try and reconstruct
experiences as much as possible so
looking at the materiality of the site
and how is how it was experienced but
there's also other things that were
interested in doing so we've just
started the project for instance to look
at very fine residues of building
activity carpentry pollution from fires
captured in the cementum in individuals
teeth so again taking the experiences we
might posit from the architectural
spaces back to the individuals buried in
the growth so I suppose the next decade
will be undertaken with research on that
and trying to write all of this up and I
just want to finish with one last thing
which is not really on topic for this
lecture series but just to say a very
big part of our work has been community
engagement and so we've published three
books and led a series of working in
local schools but also sessions in the
primary schools sessions for the three
local communities that live around
and the reason I want to mention that
here is what I find quite interesting is
when we went to present on what we've
been working on in our research themes
they weren't interested in the Pharaohs
they weren't interested in the temple
everyone was interested in what people
ate what they died of what the diseases
were could those diseases still be
around today and so on and so it was
really encouraging that the local
community are as interested in the
bottom-up approach to the site as we are
but all of this stuff is online as well
and our web sites there and it just
remains me to thank our our funders
particularly Qatar Sudan archaeological
project and of course everyone whose
research I've been drawing on this
evening thank you sensation of the
material from from one place
Wow we need to take a few questions yeah
sure
I'm going to take the privilege of being
the the host and asking you about so
this chronology of the abandonment of Mr
West would coincide with the problems in
Egypt and the 1150 SBC or so and we know
that's now related to some extent anyway
so it looks like it's a similar story
but people are is that this then how do
we understand how the Nile is affecting
people's movement away from Amara West
two points across the river is it or
yeah how would you well what what's that
story would you I'd say the majority of
state activity if you want to call it
that is very much focused in the early
19th dynasty so you've building of the
town under SETI the first on the basis
of stamped bricks um enclosure wall the
temple at least two phases the temple on
the ramps is a second and then a series
of other Kings add inscriptions or sorry
I should say inscriptions are added
under their reigns of their names and
also other officials deputies have
cursed the odd Viceroy who's visiting
and so on but there's a real full of
inactivity but it doesn't completely
disappear but I think what we're showing
archaeologically through the ceramic
evidence but also these these River
dates is that the abandonment is perhaps
taking longer than the the period of
Egyptian occupation as far as we know of
this area and that the use of the place
the the view of it as a sacred place for
burying people is continuing for a
couple of centuries at least
longer than that and this remains a very
archaeologically busy region right
through until today but there's nothing
on that north bank and it's just
unbelievably so this is an area where on
our island which is verdant and green
this is Araneta it's made possible
because they're using diesel water pumps
today until the 1950s and 60s good
operating Sakia there and the water
wheels but what's quite interesting is
that several people have tried to create
I mean as a shortage of farmland in
Sudan people have tried to create with
mechanical irrigation zones for palm
tree groves and also other types of
fields quite narrow mara West and
they've all failed after a couple of
years
it's just that battle against the the
environment and I think we have to map
that back into the past where they
didn't have hose aids I'll open up to
you guys questions comments thoughts I'm
going to ask you to use this microphone
so we have it recorded on our YouTube
mark you made about being able to
identify which parts of the house were
used for a livestock raising and being
able to differentiate if we don't like
pigs at the bottom of the stairs
but then in a room just separated by one
wall larger livestock like like goats
and you said that the the ground
suggested it was it was trampled over a
long period time what does that look
like is it is it just the desert is much
more compactly pressed together or so
when we excavate these spaces the kind
of dung rich deposits look quite I mean
the brown basically and they have a
certain feel to them compared to the
Nile silt heavy deposits but it's really
only when we get down to a micro
archaeological level so back in the lab
Matt's work on the micro morphology
slides that we actually start to see the
details and the details are astounding I
mean sometimes you're seeing individual
splashes of water on a surface and so on
so where I would see a floor with my
eyes we might in the micro morphology
being seeing 18 to 20 individual events
which might be intentional or simply
trampled or water trampled so in terms
of the dung sometimes we see
evidence of pellets so the coprolites
that have been deposited while wet
because they have cracked in situ as it
were as that as they dried out but then
we see ones where the pellets are all
broken up suggesting this kind of
intensity of trampling and then in terms
of I mean the interpretation of pig is
based on the fact that these are
omnivore coprolites so you have lots of
crushed up bone and so on and them they
could be human but we think that was
quite unlikely so that's why we're
pretty confident they're pigs and we
know pigs are being kept here because of
we have butchery marks on pig bones and
so on so yeah they're quite distinctive
deposits but the stories were able to
tell is only because of the micro
morphology one I should say one of the
difficulties of micro morphology is you
can't do it everywhere because you could
just be inundated with data but it
allows you at least to see certain
patterns and to be aware that they may
be possible in other spaces and it's
also very important in showing us that
you can't rely on the architecture of a
room which might look the same over a
hundred years nothing happening but the
micro morphology or the depositors can
tell you it's used to change massively
would the mycenaean stirrup jars have
been used for olive oil or for what
other products we haven't done residue
analysis on those in fact we undertook a
program about eight years ago of residue
analysis looking for lipid remains in
our particular cooking pots because we
were interested in the distinction
potential distinction between Nubian and
Egyptian food ways and patterns of
consumption and processing and so on and
we found nothing it seems that in very
arid environments lipid preservation is
very very poor having said that we're
about to start a new project because new
methodology has been developed in the
last couple of years by a couple of labs
in in the UK so we're gonna rerun those
samples so so fingers cross but we
haven't tried those on the on the
Mycenaean vessels so it's unclear do
they have their original contents in
them or have they been traded several
times and it's actually the object
itself that's kind of an exotic thing so
we don't know other comments questions
you mentioned right off the bat there's
a population of 7,500 Nubians captured
and even considering that number is made
up somehow what's the population
estimate for mr West at its height would
you say and the Nubian populations
surrounding it yeah it's a good question
I mean I think very low is the best
answer I can give for MROs so in its in
its initial iteration as if you will
incarnation probably only 20 to 30
houses there so on the basis of kind of
contemporary contemporaneous Theban
evidence from pepper I you know you
might be looking at six or seven people
in a house so that that's population
maybe only two or three hundred that
changes with the increasing density of
houses and this this suburban sprawl as
we call it out to the west and there
might be another suburban out to the
east
buried under sheets of sand we're never
going to get to it but we're talking
very very small how much the hinterland
could have supported in terms of desert
and perhaps also semi-nomadic
populations is something we haven't
looked at yet and I think that's why our
desert encampment work has been really
interesting but is only the tip of the
iceberg we and many others need to start
looking at those rural sites where in
the Donga reach you have these
originally these three Nile channels is
very fertile
still is today with mechanical aid up
here it's very different you're relying
probably on seasonally inundated spaces
one of the projects we're about to start
again Dalton is looking at these dry
stone river walls that cross parts of
the parts of the the old palea channels
are they something to do with
agriculture these are all questions
we're beginning to look at but we have a
very little understanding of what's
going out so on outside these pharaonic
towns this is a bipartite question aside
from the copper lights do you have any
other more substantial remains of the
livestock and if you do have you
performed similar strontium analyses on
their teeth to see their origins yes so
we have we have good preservation of
faunal bone essentially so colleagues in
the University of Southampton are
working on that and as I mentioned it's
a pretty typical array so it's about a
third a third a third in terms of cattle
pigs and sheep goat there's a small
amount of duck and there's a couple of
examples of ibex a--'s and gazelles but
very little actually in terms of wild
fauna some of it has but remarks on it
some of it particularly from our rubbish
dumps has rodent gnawing marks on it so
again that's helping us think about the
environment these people were living in
we've we've not done a systematic
program of isotope analysis on the on
the animal bones we have done a little
bit as kind of control points but
largely on rodents because they don't
travel so far but that would be
something interesting to look at because
one of the big questions at all these
sites particularly at their startup
point is how much they are being
supplied by the state whether it's from
Egypt or elephantine a or other entrepot
Xin Nubia that's a question we haven't
looked at in detail yet but but I should
say the kill off patterns of the of the
livestock is suggestive of much of the
livestock being brought up at or near
the site and I'm sorry I should just add
to that to clarify we also have the
whole skeletons there's it's not the
case that we're only getting certain
cuts of pay Gore cow we there's a good
representation
whole skeletal body
so relating to the like dietary
breakdown of Emory versus barley is that
roughly in line with with how the actual
like agricultural produce of the area
would have would have come out is there
any indication of importing or exporting
any of these products so the the array
of cereals that we find are consistent
with what you get in New Kingdom Egypt
as known from sites such as such as
Amarna we we have a bit like the
skeletons we have all the bits of the of
the cereals so we're pretty sure they're
being grown there and they're not
arriving in partly processed or fully
processed forms such as such as grain
and that's where the phytolith analysis
comes in because it allows us to pick up
the parts of the plants that you don't
usually see in the chart or the
desiccated record so it remains an open
question we don't have any any evidence
for instance texturally from the site
about grain deliveries so I think we're
assuming there would have been a fair
amount of agricultural land around
particularly seasonally so that the town
is founded on a on an alluvial island
essentially and presumably it and the
island adjacent to it would have
provided pretty good agriculture if you
look at Nubia today further upstream
islands are generally very good for
agriculture so I'm assuming most of it
was grown locally but we don't have
proof for that at the moment other
questions or comments
I think today um Beaulieu had of quartz
and possible gold dust in it is do you
know where the closest mines are today
is that part of the raison d'etre of the
actual settlement itself because I know
no sabían solid they always speculated
these were kind of gold mining / temple
town / whatever is that kind of same
overlay present in Amara West possibly
or is there some of the economic raison
d'être that would explain why we so 10
years on I'm still struggling with this
question right you know why was it
founded I mean so it's like okay spend
some Pam Rose who are working at sesame
have posited reasonably enough that the
site is it's very close to quartz
deposits that are still visible today
but perhaps that they became unworkable
or exhausted in terms of the extraction
technology and did that lead to the
moving of the capital further the local
colonial capital to somewhere like MROs
possibly there's no really big quartz
deposits around
however the Clemmons have suggest that
there was a shift in the ramesside
period towards collecting quartz pebbles
in the in the wadi runoffs particularly
on the east bank and that those towns
might be associated with that so that's
one possibility
interestingly the encampments which we
looked at the early 18th dynasty ones do
have evidence this quartz working as
well
but it just might not be on a very very
grand scale I should stress that pot
with the quartz in it we didn't find out
I don't know where it is so I mean
Fuhrman describes it as having these
gold bearing veins in it but what we do
find is we find courts and chippings
courts chippings in most of the houses
as well as these very distinctive dark
stone grinding implements so this
there's something going on and there's
the president the presence of a Menem
hat who's a subscribe of gold counting
about how big an industry it was I don't
know other suggestions for the location
you know the reason for choosing the
shift tomorrow s is you know did the
island environment was that an
attractive thing so I is a very big
island and that has advantages and
disadvantages somewhat flippantly the
name et the biting fly question has been
brought up and how horrific that is a
at Sai and whether moving might have
been attractive or is it something to do
with movement of groups in the desert
and so there's also Amara West is at the
start of the road out this Salima oasis
so that got something to do with it so
no it's still an open question and one
of the things I should say is that while
we've got a lot of evidence of activity
in the desert
going back to 9,000 BC on the Amara West
Island itself or the New Kingdom or the
ramesside material it seems to be built
on the natural alluvium there's nothing
earlier we have a few eighteenth dynasty
objects but they're presumably brought
from somewhere else we don't have any
18th dynasty pottery or
clear evidence that there is activity at
the side of that date so so yeah those
there's lots of potential answers but no
no definite understanding at the moment
please join me in thanking Neil Spencer
[Applause]
[Music]